number 17 goes 17 yards and it counts as
a touchdown pass for pat shermer's son
kyle even though all he did was catch
the snap and hot potato it forward to
the second round pick out of georgia
chris hey look nicole hardman tyreek
hill sammy watkins travis kelsey kareem
hunt
nick uh not nick chubb he they used to i
got korean i got it all screwed up now
they don't have the running backs i'm
mashing up my teams the browns
for saving
yeah they don't have kareem anymore
damien williams when he's healthy but
forget about the running backs they got
the receivers in the tight end and off
they go and uh me cole hardman could be
a very special player for the chiefs
chris yeah uh you know you know my
favorite phrase right mike i mean you
talk about rockets up butts i mean
nicole hardman's got two of them just
like tyree kill he might be the eventual
replacement of a guy like tyree kill
i mean he is that kind of speed he is a
home run hitter it's amazing really that
they found a guy so similar really raw
not really a real wide receiver but
they're going to try to he's kind of a
weapon like tyree kill and they're going
to try to develop him into being a
weapon for that offense in case they
can't get tyree kill straightened out
off the field or find the right contract
situation for them right that's a tag
and trade like they did with d4 it's
that simple if you don't want to keep
the guy you've got the replacement if
you don't want to pay him 20 million a
year then you keep me cole hardman who's
going to cost you far less than that
over the next four seasons all right
time to play a little fill in the blanks
coming out of week one of the preseason
chris sims most impressive week one
performance was well i'm gonna go i'm
using i'm gonna use two here okay i'm
gonna go with the m m's all right the m
ms as in mayfield and mahomes okay i'm
gonna go oh wait a minute you only get
one well tough you only get one i put it
into a nice uh synonymous star wars so i
don't know what the hell i'm trying to
say it was harmonious is what it was
eminem's is creativity okay
but yes mahomes in mayfield they just
impressed me why i mean hey both of
these guys you know going into year two
with starters all these expectations
right they just get out there oh hurry
up offense or baker mayfield doom doom
doom touchdown oh no big deal just an 89
yard drive for a touchdown no big deal
oh all this pressure and we're worried
about our offense it will look good yeah
no problem and then they'll throw a
laser for a touchdown and then okay with
patrick mahomes same thing coming off
that year 55 you know 50 touchdowns 5
000 yards to get one drive and just be
that efficient and that impressive just
like you never missed a beat just like
riding a bike i'm gonna give it to them
because there is such thing as that
sophomore slump everybody telling you
how great you are and everything like
that and they just seem unfazed by that
they're very humble and they deliver
right away to like basically say oh no
sophomore slump here we're coming out
the same guys we saw last year i'm gonna
stick to the actual
script here and pick one and and i wish
you had just gone with mayfield then i
could have taken my homes because for me
it is my homes and here's here's the
thing
when you watch preseason football yeah
there's
there's something about it
now you know going in it's not real
football right yeah
but but there's something about the way
let me give you the example with the
vikings game right on new offense and
and kirk cousins moved him down the
field but there was something about it
that felt artificial and antiseptic
right that just doesn't ooze out this
this is the authentic vikings offense
that this is really what we're gonna see
and and
with patrick mahomes
it feels different yeah it felt
different it felt like a regular season
performance it felt like this is the guy
here he is like you said hasn't missed a
beat this is the guy and he's ready to
go and it doesn't feel like the
preseason he is ready to go he is that
he is did you just let me go let me play
and and this is him there's nothing
artificial or restrained about any of it
and that's what was amazing to me and it
was very we talk all the time chris
about quarterbacks
not protecting themselves and they can't
have the presence of mind and they don't
have the presence of mind in that moment
to to set the ego aside and do the smart
thing and mahomes was running into the
end zone now it's a preseason game it
doesn't mean anything he was running
into the end zone what did he do he knew
to hit the deck yep he knows how to
protect himself he wasn't going to be
you know he gets thousands of fans there
that want to have that excitement pad my
home's diving into the end zone no i'm
going to hit the deck he probably could
have made it it's not worth it and and
having that instinct is the thing that
means he's more likely than not to stay
healthy for as long as he wants to play
football because he's going to avoid
those tough situations yeah but that's
what impressed me even though it was
wonder i wanted more i'm with you mike
and it because it felt like a regular
season game watching patrick mahomes
yeah it just because he's just he's
amazing his skill set of course there's
talent around him and you know that like
they don't have to like over game plan
or manage a situation with a guy like
him he's just so good he's just gonna
they can call all their normal training
wheels you know beginning at training
camp type plays and he still makes it
look like what you're saying like it was
week three and they game plan to some
team to find these explosive plays no
not really they're just that good he's
just that good and and uh they're off
and running already and i think we're
going to see a lot of similar results to
what we saw last year out of that
offense
next topic i think blank was the rookie
qb that had the best debut singular okay
singular not three okay all right i'll
go singular here all right i gotta go
with daniel jones here for for a lot of
reasons i mean hey kyler murray
like i wanna say was more impressive
okay so stick with daniel jones but i am
pleased i am leave mine alone yes please
i'm going there i'm just trying to
explain my my answer okay
kyler murray i mean he's like oh my gosh
that's amazing but daniel jones for the
situation that he's in and
how badly this could have been a
nightmare if he made one bad decision
and threw an interception or missed a
bunch of passes then everybody would
have just piled on even more oh my gosh
the giants picked him number six what a
disaster i think he had more pressure on
him than any of the quarterbacks uh that
were drafted last year as far as a week
one performance and he answered the bell
and not only answered the belt mike a
lot of a lot of what we talked about on
friday just looked the part looked like
he belonged ball popped out of his hands
good presence in the pocket not phased
by the big lights or anything of the
situation so uh kudos to daniel jones
yeah and and what are the giants looking
for in a quarterback gm dave gettleman
said a guy who can handle the pressure
and the scrutiny of the new york market
yeah so far so good for daniel jones
this is a team that we think has no plan
or a bad plan i think they have a genius
plan for easing daniel jones into the
point where the fans are going to be
clamoring for him and it's going to make
that transition from eli manning to
daniel jones much easier than anyone
ever expected it would have been
i'm going with kyla murray though there
is something magical about this kid and
you and i have been rooting for him and
hoping that he will look the part and
the way
the two things the way the ball comes
out of his hand and the way that it
arrives it just arrived there's a
suddenness when it gets to the receiver
that you just don't see
it's like getting your hands up you're
taking it right in the face receiver i
mean it it is and i think it's because
he's so little that it looks as
impressive as it does but i think no
matter how short or tall he is that ball
has some pop on it on both ends and all
the way in between this kid can throw
and we haven't seen him run yet that
still is being kept in the garage but a
great thrower of the football as you
would say chris yes and i can't wait to
see him on thursday night against the
raiders me neither uh yeah and and you
know just to
pile on to what you're saying yeah
there's the ball flies out of his hands
and then just how quickly he can do it
but yet it looks so smooth and cool even
though he's doing it quickly i mean it's
just
i'm with you i mean this as far as pure
physical
like oh this was amazing make your jaw
drop type stuff i mean kyle and murray
had me salivating for more where i think
you and i both wanted to see one more
series but uh it is what it is and we'll
see enough of them this week but i'm
certainly excited to watch him play this
year
all right two more if we can jam it man
here blank was the most surprising thing
i saw over the weekend well this this is
a tough one here i guess i guess i'm
gonna go because i'm gonna go with ryan
tannehill and his performance not that
i'm like like oh my gosh i can't believe
he did that but there's i don't know
there's not a lot that just jumping out
to me as far as this category is
concerned but i think it's just it's
it's it's surprising to s because i'm
i'm intrigued to see where this
quarterback battle goes in tennessee
okay i know there's no battle with
marcus mariota but i watch ryan
tannehill and watch back that game the
other night on film and i just go
wow i mean he's every bit as good as
marcus mariota i mean his skill set is
very similar and i'm not so sure he's
not a better passer and a better thrower
than marcus mariot a little more natural
of a quarterback and he made a variety
of different throws in the game when i
went back and watched it yesterday to
where you know it was surprising that
they just unleashed him i guess is what
i wanted to say and let him put up two
touchdowns and some gaudy numbers
because i think it's only going to
increase the chatter of ooh is he
breathing down mario yoda's neck after
mariota you know wasn't bad but
certainly didn't do anything special
with his four for eight performance i
think or somewhere along those lines but
i just find that one to be a surprising
intriguing situation overall mike
mine is uh very situational very
specific at the end of the buccaneers
steerless game on friday night with
about 10 seconds left the buccaneer
scored a touchdown wild down eight
points and bruce aryan's veteran coach
of the bucks he sent his team out to go
for two and it would have forced
overtime yeah you don't want overtime in
a pc's game nobody wants overtime in a
preseason game and and the one guy that
i would assume would just send out the
the extra point unit and just make it a
one-point loss and go home would be
bruce arians why would he care about
whether you win or lose a preseason game
it was really stunning to me and and the
mistake came they were down 16 uh or
they were down they they went for two
earlier it was down 14 they went for two
i think that's what it was and uh and
then put it back at that eight-point gap
right uh they it just
that really shocked me because there's
no need for overtime in the preseason
they should get rid of it anyway but i
would have thought bruce arians would
have not even even taken the chance of
sending that to more time and expose his
players to more risk all right real
quickly it's only the preseason but
blank has me worried the eagles
quarterback backup quarterback situation
i think that's the most worrying thing
i've seen after week one i'm not worried
about a whole lot through the nfl right
now but yeah that's a super bowl team
carson wench has had injury issues nate
sutfeld you know breaks his wrist not
going to be back for a while and now
we're going to leave it to a rookie and
clayton thorson and cody kessler who
were just on you know one's an unproven
young commodity the other one's just you
know not that good for lack of a better
phrase so that scares me that that's
something i'd be worried about if i'm an
eagles fan right now
yeah and for me it's just the raiders
this antonio brown stuff we haven't
talked about it from a football
perspective but him not being there the
distraction that this creates the issues
that this that will hover over the team
until this is resolved that this this
sets the entire project back and they
have so many tough games this year they
have to go to winnipeg for a preseason
game in london for a regular season game
they have a lot of adversity this year
they are already dealing with a ton of
it
unrelated to football yeah so uh this
could shape up to be another rough year
for the oakland raiders in their last
season in oakland
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports